no
[Música]
qué podemos hacer para como país lograr
un 5 mundo en octubre del 2013 en
toronto el perú aceptó el reto de
ejecutar los juegos panamericanos y
parapanamericanos
yo me embarqué estás en ese desafío
en casi exactamente tres años pues
faltando me dos años 10 meses para
ejecutarlo y tenía un reto parecido a
esto era una apuesta muy riesgosa estaba
poniendo mi carrera en juego pero esta
vez a diferencia de otras oportunidades
no era si fracasaba era fracasar a nivel
internacional y con ello también me
llevaba el prestigio de nuestro país sin
embargo lo acepté porque creen que lo
podía hacer
tenía algunas habilidades en el campo
inmobiliario en gestión etcétera pero
una tremenda pasión por el deporte y mi
deporte de toda la vida ha sido la tabla
en fin cuál era ese reto era recibir
aproximadamente en la tercera semana de
julio más o menos a seis mil seiscientos
ochenta deportistas para los
panamericanos
para competir en 39 deportes y ellos
venían de 41 países semanas después de
terminar los panamericanos había que
enfrentar el reto de los
parapanamericanos eran 1890 para
deportistas de 33 países y 17 deportes
pero además en conjunto con técnicos y
dirigentes llegaban a 15.000 personas
pero no contábamos con la
infraestructura necesaria para poderlos
hacer así como por ejemplo el último
centro acuático porque dije bueno vamos
a utilizarlo era del año 62 y no cumplía
con ninguna de las exigencias en la
villa deportiva nacional teníamos un
estadio de atletismo que la pista se
caía a pedazos y que decir de las
tribunas que es que ahí estaban
presentes
en fin había decisiones que tomar
y cosas que optimizar para poder llegar
a tiempo pero en todos los juegos
multideportivos como olimpiadas y paz y
panamericanos por ejemplo similares en
otras partes del mundo se daban leyes
especiales nosotros le pedimos al
gobierno en ese momento que nos ayudara
con algunas de ellas y entre algunas de
las sesiones importantes muchas que
tuvieron que tomar fue realizar un
convenio de gobierno a gobierno con
algún país para que nos hiciera llevar
estos juegos a cabo finalmente después
de un proceso de negociación con otro
país el primer nivel optamos por el
reino unido que tenía la experiencia de
haber organizado unos excelentes juegos
en londres
como paso siguiente necesitábamos
empezar y para ello convocamos
junio del año 17 rose zone donde
llamamos a un montón de empresas para
que se presentaran y mostrarle los
juegos tuvimos una asistencia
excepcional a más de 800 personas 300
empresas y empezamos y logramos iniciar
nuestros procesos de licitación y en la
primera licitación en general tuvimos
una asistencia de 40 de más de 40
empresas postulantes para ejecutar estos
juegos estos nos den alguna manera nos
devolvió el alma al cuerpo porque
pudimos ver que si había interés y que
si podíamos llegar pero teníamos que
utilizar leyes internacionales porque en
nuestra legislación lamentablemente era
muy complicado o sea normalmente en
en el perú por ejemplo se cae licitación
en el sector público se presentaba 1.8
empresas por licitación nosotros
llegamos a 40 de promedio pero siempre
el que ganaba ganaba uno perdía más de
uno dos o tres se quedaban afuera ellos
impugnaban y las cosas no funcionaba
entonces teníamos claro que no íbamos a
poder seguir adelante por ese camino
entonces con los modelos que utilizamos
de contratación modelos internacionales
modernos que ya se usan en otros lugares
súper transparentes logramos avanzar
muchísimo y ver cosas por ejemplo en el
estadio de atletismo también mejoramos
el factor viento era muy integridad muy
importante entonces logramos diseñar
modelos para evitar que esto sucediera
podía presentarse mejoras en el camino y
con estos modelos de contratación
también podríamos ajustar
y los diseños para construir más rápido
y tener valor por el dinero también
pudimos incorporar profesionales de todo
el mundo y en los llamados de gitanos
olímpicos lo que realmente vinieron a
aportar con sus experiencias y nos
permitieron puedes avanzar de una forma
bastante fuerte y sabiéndose ellos
equivocados quizás en otros eventos aquí
por supuesto los astros se alinearon y
muy pocas equivocaciones tuvieron
con estas
ayuda con este complemento pudimos
avanzar muy fuerte y creamos la
infraestructura necesaria e incluso
pudimos ahorrar dinero tuvimos alrededor
que intervenir aproximadamente 40 sedes
y por ejemplo en villamaría se decidió
para el hockey y el rugby y otros
deportes otras siete disciplinas y en la
villa deportiva nacional en la videna
hicimos un estadio para el atletismo te
echamos un velo como que se estaba por
caer a pedazos y además este en otros
sitios red construimos por ejemplo el
estadio de san marcos que se estaba
cayendo a pedazos y luego volvimos de
clase mundial reconstruimos en el
coliseo dibós que también estaba en
proceso de caída en fin logramos una
serie de mejoras pero además de esto
como muy pocos juegos se ha sucedido y
creo que investigando no encontramos
ninguno lo hicimos por debajo del
presupuesto el presupuesto inicial
asignado para nosotros fue 5 mil
millones de soles
se parece bastante pero sin embargo lo
reducimos a 4.100 generando un ahorro
muchos dirán
[Aplausos]
pero bueno no todo fueron obras no
porque eran importantes y no se hacían
estas obras no avanzábamos y logramos
integrar al país y logramos en todo
jugaron y por ejemplo nos pasaron una
serie de anécdotas ustedes muchos se
acordarán de la ceremonia de
inauguración que fue el 26 de julio no
de de este año un viernes que fue
extraordinaria movió a todos nuestros
sentimientos
y ésta por si acaso hicimos cuatro
ceremonias recorrido por todo el país de
la antorcha nos costó creo que la mitad
de lo que costó una ceremonia en las
olimpiadas anteriores no salía a las 5
de la mañana del día siguiente es el
cuarto de control que teníamos lo que
llamamos una especie de cuarto de guerra
que está con gente trabajando las 24
horas me llaman y me dicen carlos
tenemos un gran problema
y cuál es este nada no se han presentado
100 choferes para llevar a los
deportistas su cds de competencia un
cometido dije éste era el baño echar un
poquito de agua no y éste elige qué hago
bueno tenía los teléfonos de los
comandantes generales las fuerzas
armadas cambiar el ejército marina
aviación a un amigo que tenía una
empresa de buses a otros que exista que
tenían redes de contactos y en hora y
media
resolvimos el problema todos los
deportistas llegaron a tiempos
[Aplausos]
tuvimos 34.000 viajes en buses no creo
que
a pesar del tráfico de lima a partir de
ahí tampoco ningún deportista llegó a su
competencia tarde el único que casi casi
llega fue un deportista boliviano
como conocían y más decidió hoy por su
cuenta
hasta el presidente morales estaba atrás
de ellos
y éste tuvo que mandar la moto para que
para que lo ubique donde estaba
felizmente llegó y ganó la única medalla
que tuvo bolivia
otros datos por ejemplo hace un año
exactamente empezamos con la captura de
voluntarios necesitamos entre 30 y 40
mil voluntarios porque para juegos
íbamos a tener 12 mil para los
panamericanos y 7000 para los
parapanamericanos ese mismo día que
abrimos e hicimos conferencia de prensa
se registraron 6.000 personas
en diciembre teníamos 70.000 y en
febrero le tuve que decir a la jefa de
voluntariado que por favor para la mano
porque habíamos llegado a 6000 y no
había forma de reparar esto entonces con
ellos ya se acordarán ustedes los
voluntarios fueron excelentes no hoy
tuvimos casi 800 voluntarios de diversas
partes del mundo 400 millones de
personas vieron los juegos
principalmente en las américas y en el
resto del mundo se repartieron 700 mil
raciones de alimentos a todos los
competidores y jueces etcétera y en
generamos medio millón de empleos
directos indirectos o inducidos
el turismo que se calcula se ha generado
de acuerdo a la canatur fueron 350
millones de dólares
estos fueron los primeros juegos verdes
que se hicieron en los resultados que
nos han dado que se han evitado tardar
1.500 árboles 580 mil personas que se
hicieron a los panamericanos y 170 mil a
los parapanamericanos que para nosotros
fue un juguete digamos esfuerzo especial
y eso fue más que en todos los juegos
anteriores se transmitieron mil horas de
televisión de los juegos eso era como
invertir en una campaña del perú de
aproximadamente 300 millones de dólares
nos llegó una encuesta de ipsos guerra
aceptación de los juegos ya era desde el
94 por ciento se han escrito más de 80
mil artículos en todo el mundo eso
equivale aproximadamente a mil millones
de dólares esto en perú se ha mostrado
al mundo pero lo que más
nos alegró fueron las 40 medallas de oro
perdón o no de oro
las 40 medallas entero jugó
[Aplausos]
en los panamericanos y 15 medallas en
los parapanamericanos pero pablo aquí
está hoy con israel solo está puro que
ganó su medalla de oro él tuvo un
accidente que perdió una pierna vive en
españa pero súper emocionado con su
medalla
logramos que todo el país participar
el taxista se acuerda de esa propaganda
del taxista que dejaba a los carros
cuando venían los buses
también participó la gente todos ustedes
cuando llegaban donde un turista que me
preguntaba y les daba indicaciones la
policía las fuerzas armadas los
municipios el poder ejecutivo el
congreso también no pero sobre todo
también participó la gran barra peruanas
que no sé
fue extraordinaria en el mundial y
dejamos un legado no solamente en las
obras deportivas que ya se están
utilizando en los diversos deportes
también muchas personas han empezado a
practicar deportes tengo una nieta de
ocho años que ganó su su medalla de
bronce en una competencia de gimnasia
del colegio y era como si hubiera ganado
en los panamericanos
también otro agregado muy importante es
que las personas con algún tipo de
discapacidad las hemos hecho visibles
imagínense a aquellas personas que
sufrieron algún problema en la vida
nacieron con algún mal congénito han
encima se han superado han hecho deporte
y en y luego vestido la camiseta de su
país y luego se acaba una medalla eso es
tremendo dunia por ejemplo ganó su
medalla y su pasaje a tokio
realmente vieron al alcalde lima con
compilar sobreviviendo caminando
encierros caminando rodando en silla de
ruedas ya la municipalidad logrado
oficio de una empresa de cemento para
poner 1200 veredas asequibles en la
ciudad de lima ayer me y un dirigente de
alianza anima me llamó sur
me llamó y me dijo ya estoy poniendo una
rampa para las sillas de ruedas en la
tribuna occidente y después la voy a
hacer en el oriente en fin otro legado
no previsto es que hemos implantado una
nueva forma de contratación para el
estado que ya se está hablando usar el
modelo de los panamericanos pero quizás
para lo más emocionante para mí cuando
entramos a este proyecto era ver a los
porque trabajamos en la viena y veíamos
a estos a los deportistas que llegaban
muy temprano practicados en la mañana en
la tarde y yo decía no les podemos
fallar ellos están trabajando fuerte
para lograr llegar a los panamericanos y
sacar medallas y lo menos que podemos
hacer nosotros es un es tratar de
cumplir y hacerlo bien cuando el
presidente de los panas sports
un chileno que fue el comité olímpico
chileno cuando perdió las teníamos la
opción de hacer los panamericanos en
santiago en el 2001 le dijo carlos este
yo me dolió mucho perder pero ahora yo
soy tu principal aliado y cuando lo dijo
hemos hecho los mejores juegos
panamericanos realmente para mí fue
inesperado pero realmente un premio para
todos aquellos deportistas y voluntarios
que se esforzaron porque esta vez si el
perú jugó completo jugó todo y realmente
estamos muy felices de haber mediado en
nuestro país estos días de orgullo en
medio de tanta turbulencia muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]